hey there and welcome to this pro flows
quick tip i am cameron
and in this short lesson i'm going to
expand
on what i talked about in a previous
video which is
camera shake in the previous video if
you haven't seen it yet i talk about how
to add
camera shake to footage and to
typography
well what if we want to add a little bit
of camera shake to a graphics to our
graphics and we have a lot of layers
here how do we do that well it's really
simple
it's just like i showed in a previous
video it just has to deal with an
adjustment layer
and the distort transform effect
so what we're going to do is we're going
to add a new adjustment layer
and we're going to apply an effect which
is distort
transform to this adjustment layer
we're going to alter option click on
position
we're going to type in wiggle and we're
going to do something like 3
and 70. and we're also going to
scale up our transform just a little bit
so we can hide some of these edges that
we now see
so maybe we'll try 105
and we're just going to see if
everything is kind of covered
i could see a little bit there on the
edge so maybe 108
and let's preview this and see how it
looks and there we go there is our
preview
and you can see how much more
interesting this
tunnel is now with just that little bit
of camera shake it makes it look a
little bit more
imperfect a little bit more organic it
looks kind of like we're flying through
like maybe like an old star wars
video tunnel screen graphic
kind of thing you get my point you can
play around with the wiggle expression
here you can make it look
totally different but that is an
interesting way to add
the transform property to an adjustment
layer to make your graphics come
alive if you liked this video i do
recommend that you check out proflos
plus
for more exciting videos on techniques
trends and methods
in motion design